In 1982, a series of events in and around
Chicago transformed consumer safety.
On the morning of September 29,
12-year-old Mary Kellerman told
her parents she wasn’t feeling well, so they
gave her an extra-strength Tylenol capsule.
Immediately after, Mary collapsed.
She was dead by 10 am.
That same day, postal worker
Adam Janus came down with a cold.
He purchased some extra-strength
Tylenol at a supermarket.
He took two capsules and
immediately went into convulsions.
He later died in hospital.
Doctors suspected the
27-year-old had a heart attack.
After grieving at the hospital,
Adam’s family came together at his home to
comfort his wife and two small children.
His brother Stanley was so grief-stricken
he came down with a headache. He grabbed
some Tylenol from the same bottle
Adam had purchased earlier that day.
He offered some to his newly wedded wife,
Theresa. They took two capsules each.
Soon after, they collapsed.
Stanley died that day. Theresa held on
for two more days before passing away.
The unusual deaths caught the attention of
firefighters from the affected suburbs of Chicago.
Firefighter Richard Keyworth said: “‘This
is a wild stab, but maybe it’s Tylenol.”
Another firefighter who had the same suspicions
reached out to a nurse from the local community.
Nurse Helen Jensen spoke to Adam Janus’ widow and
realized all three family
members had taken Tylenol.
She thought: “It has to be the Tylenol”.
But she said the medical examiner and police
didn’t believe her and even laughed it off.
In another suburb of Chicago, Mary
Reiner was feeling woozy. She had
given birth to her fourth child two
days earlier. The hospital gave her
some Tylenol to help with her postpartum
recovery, and she also purchased some from
a store. Immediately after taking two
capsules, she felt dizzy and collapsed.
Mary died the following day…at the same
hospital where she had just given birth.
Another Mary, Mary McFarland, was taking a dinner
break in the shopping center where she worked.
The 31-year-old single mom had a migraine. She
took two Tylenol capsules and, minutes later,
collapsed. She never regained consciousness.
That evening, flight attendant
Paula Prince landed at Chicago’s
O’Hare International Airport after a long day.
She stopped at a Walgreens on her way home.
An ATM surveillance camera captured the
35-year-old purchasing the
pills that would kill her.
When she failed to show up for work,
her sister and a colleague went to her
apartment and found her lifeless body.
All seven people died after taking Tylenol.
When an investigator with the medical examiner’s
office first examined the Tylenol bottle from
Mary Kellerman’s house and the other one from
the Janus’, they smelled like bitter almonds.
The examiner knew instantly
what he was dealing with.
The odor was cyanide.
He was lucky to catch a whiff of
cyanide because only about 60% of
the population can detect the bitter almond scent.
Out of the 44 remaining capsules in the Janus’
bottle, four were found to contain cyanide.
Each capsule had between 550
to 610 milligrams of potassium
cyanide - nearly three times the
amount needed to kill someone.
Their blood samples tested
positive for cyanide poisoning.
A dogged reporter named John Flynn
Rooney received a tip and broke
the story of the poisonings before an
official press conference was called.
Stores began pulling pain
relievers from the shelves.
Chicago police drove through the streets using
loudspeakers to order people to
flush Tylenol down the toilet.
These quick actions likely saved more
lives as no further deaths occurred.
The corporation that owned Tylenol, Johnson
& Johnson, did NOT think this was the work
of an employee. It believed the capsules were
laced with cyanide after leaving the factories.
Because the poisoned capsules came
from multiple manufacturing plants.
Investigators believed someone must have taken the
bottles off store shelves, pulled the two casings
apart, laced them with poison, and then reattached
the halves before returning them to the store.
The capsule on the left is
regular Tylenol, the capsule
on the right contains cyanide. The powder is
off-white and grayish in color, and lumpier.
Store management pulled all the
Tylenol off the shelves on Thursday
The poisonings were the
biggest story in the country.
Poison control center. We’ve been receiving
calls about once every 15 seconds.
Tylenol was the most popular
pain reliever in America.
Extra strength tylenol. Aspirin-free. And
you can’t buy a more potent pain
reliever without a prescription
Tylenol controlled 37% of the over-the-counter
pain reliever market and accounted for
$400 million in sales the year before.
After the deaths, Tylenol’s
market share plummeted to 7%.
Johnson & Johnson recalled all 31
million bottles of Tylenol capsules.
More tainted capsules were found. Fortunately,
they had not been sold or consumed.
The poisonings changed how
over-the-counter drugs were packaged.
At the time, there was no protective sealing
on any over-the-counter drug bottles.
Johnson & Johnson worked with the FDA to include
safety seals which became the
norm for packaged food as well.
The company also introduced a new version of
its pill - the caplet - which was harder
to tamper with than the older capsules.
A few years later, Tylenol stopped
selling its capsule version for good.
Johnson & Johnson spent $100 million
on the recall and relaunch of Tylenol.
And it was worth it.
Within a year, Tylenol sales bounced back,
and once again became America’s
favorite over-the-counter pain reliever.
But for the families of the victims,
there was no relief from their pain.
Police had not caught the person responsible
for the deaths of their loved ones.
But they did have someone in mind.
About a week after the poisonings,
Tylenol’s manufacturer, McNeil,
a subsidiary of Johnson & Johnson,
received a letter in the mail.
Inside was a note written in all caps.
Gentlemen: as you can see it is easy to
place cyanide (both potassium and sodium)
into capsules sitting on store shelves. and
since the cyanide is inside the gelatin,
it is easy to get buyers to swallow the bitter
pill. another beauty is that cyanide operates
quickly. it takes so very little, and there
will be no time to take countermeasures.
If you don’t mind the publicity of these
little capsules, then do nothing. so far,
i’ve spent less than 50 dollars and it
takes me less than 10 minutes per bottle.
If you want to stop the killing
then wire $1,000,000 to bank account
number #84-49-597 at continental
illinois bank, Chicago, Illinois.
Was this really the killer?
The FBI discovered that the bank account
belonged to Frederick Miller McCahey,
the heir to the Miller Brewing fortune.
However, police didn’t
believe he wrote the letter.
The bank account mentioned in the note had been
closed after McCahey shut down his travel agency.
The letter was traced to his
agency’s Pitney-Bowes stamp machine.
Was the letter writer someone who had
access to the agency and held a grudge?
Police learned that one of
McCahey’s former employees,
Nancy Richardson, was upset that her
final paycheck of $511 had bounced.
Nancy’s husband, Robert Richardson, had
angrily confronted McCahey over the check.
The Richardsons had moved out of Chicago
just weeks before the poisonings.
When police issued a warrant
for the couple’s arrest,
they discovered they had been using fake names.
Robert and Nancy Richardson were aliases.
Their real names were: James and LeAnn Lewis.
Authorities tracked them down in
New York City and arrested James
Lewis at the New York Public Library.
Lewis’ fingerprints matched those on
the extortion letter sent to Johnson & Johnson.
He said he never intended
to collect the cash and was
simply trying to embarrass his wife’s former boss.
Lewis may have been the letter
writer, but was he the Tylenol killer?
During his sentencing hearing in the
extortion case, he sat down with CBS 2.
Did you commit the Tylenol murders?
I did not.
Do you know who did?
I do not know who did, no.
But investigators were not convinced.
Clip A new development in the Tylenol murder case.
Some believe Lewis resembled
the man caught on surveillance
video watching flight attendant Paula
Prince purchase the Tylenol capsules.
Investigators were fortunate to get
this shot because the ATM security
camera only captured still photos
when someone was using the machine.
As investigators dug into James Lewis’ background,
they learned he had a troubled
past and faced a murder charge.
When he was a little boy,
his father abandoned him,
then his mother. A couple adopted him at the
age of two and raised him on a farm in Missouri.
As a teen, he attacked his adoptive mother with
an axe and spent time in a mental institution.
He attended the University
of Missouri-Kansas City,
where he met LeAnn. They
married and had a daughter.
Toni Ann was born with Down’s syndrome
and had other health problems.
By all accounts, Lewis doted on her.
An FBI report stated: “He never showed anger
about Toni’s condition or blamed anyone.”
The couple opened a tax accounting business
in Kansas City called Lewis & Lewis.
One of their clients was an
elderly man named Raymond West.
West lived a simple, retired life
after working as a truck driver.
He kept the rose bushes in front of his home
perfectly pruned and took walks every day.
But one day, he…disappeared.
When a friend went to his home to
check on him, he found a note taped
to the front door which read: “Ray is out of
town until Thursday. For further, call Jim”.
It was written on Lewis & Lewis stationery.
When West’s friend returned to
the house a few weeks later,
he smelled a foul odor emanating
from a bedroom and called police.
When police arrived, they looked
in the attic, and to their horror,
found Raymond West’s decomposing
body. His legs had been severed.
Police quickly zoned in on a suspect: James Lewis.
West had made out a cheque to Lewis
for $5,000 dated the last day anyone
had heard from him. A handwriting expert
concluded the check was likely forged.
When police searched Lewis’ cars,
they found dozens of canceled checks
belonging to West. They also found a rope
matching the rope found around West’s body.
Lewis denied killing West
and said the rope was from
the time he helped West rebuild his
home after the flood a year before.
There was plenty of circumstantial
evidence linking Lewis to the crime,
and prosecutors charged him with murder.
However, the case was dismissed
due to a technicality.
Lewis should have been read his Miranda rights
before questioning when he was arrested and
brought to the police station. This is the
“You have the right to remain silent” warning.
But police never read him his rights.
A judge ruled that police acted
improperly in arresting Lewis…and
threw out the evidence taken from Lewis’ cars
and all the statements he made to police.
Prosecutors lost some of their
best circumstantial evidence.
There was one other piece of evidence.
A fingerprint was found on the pulley
used to hoist West’s body into the attic,
but police had not been able
to match the print to Lewis.
Three years later, the FBI used state-of-the-art
equipment to confirm that the
fingerprint belonged to Lewis.
However, Lewis was never re-charged with murder.
A reason someone is not charged despite
new evidence is that it might not be
sufficient to meet the burden of
proof required for a conviction.
What about the Tylenol murders -
could Lewis have been behind those?
Investigators believed he had a motive.
And it had to do with his daughter.
Lewis’ daughter Toni Ann had a heart
defect that required multiple surgeries.
When she was five, the sutures used to repair
the hole in her heart tore apart, and she died.
A federal investigation later confirmed that
the polypropylene sutures that tore were sold
under the brand name Prolene, according to
records reviewed by the Chicago Tribune.
Prolene was produced by….Johnson &
Johnson, the company that made Tylenol.
Lewis blamed the drug manufacturer
for the death of his little girl,
according to a police sergeant
quoted in a Memphis newspaper.
He served 13 years for extortion for writing
the ransom letter to Johnson & Johnson.
While in prison, he produced elaborate sketches
that showed how cyanide powder
could be packed into capsules.
But he insisted he was innocent and was simply
trying to help investigators solve the crime.
He explained to the Chicago Tribune, “I
could tell you how Julius Caesar was killed,
but that does not mean I was the killer.”
Lewis was not the only suspect. Police
investigated around 400 people, including
Roger Arnold, who worked in the warehouse of
one of the stores that sold the tainted Tylenol.
Arnold also worked with the father of one of the
victims, Mary Reiner, who had just given birth.
The owner of a bar that Arnold frequented
grew concerned after a couple of regulars
reported that Arnold had been talking about
possessing cyanide and working on a project.
The bar owner subsequently tipped off police.
When Arnold found out, he became
furious and ended up shooting a
man he mistakenly believed was the bar owner.
The man he shot, a father of three, died.
And Arnold was sentenced to 30 years in prison.
But there was still no one
behind bars for the poisonings.
A few weeks after the murders, the Chicago
Tribune appealed to the killer to come forward.
Journalist Bob Greene focused on the suffering
of the parents of young Mary
Kellerman. His article read:
If you are the Tylenol killer,
some of this may matter to you.
Or it may make no difference at all.
If you are the Tylenol killer, though,
you may be harboring just the vaguest curiosity
about the people on the other end of your plan:
the people who were unfortunate enough
to purchase the bottles you had touched.
If you are curious, come to
a small house on a quiet,
winding street in Elk Grove Village. Come to
1425 Armstrong Lane. The people who live there,
Dennis and Jeanna Kellerman, feel
you have already been inside, anyway.
If you are the Tylenol killer,
you should know one more thing:
Mary’s mother can’t have any more children.
Mary was her only baby; you might be interested
in knowing that Mary was born one month premature,
and that as she entered the world her mother was
scared because she was not crying. But the doctor
smiled and said, “It’s all right; she’s only
sleeping.” And she was; she was a quiet child,
and because the Kellermans knew she would be their
only child, she was especially precious to them.
If you are the Tylenol killer, you might
want to know that Mary’s parents always
considered themselves to be overly protective.
The reason Mary’s parents were like that was
that they knew something that a
12-year-old girl couldn’t know.
They knew that the world can at times be
a cruel place, and that parents have a
duty to protect their child from dangers
the child might not even know are there.
They thought they knew about every
danger that could possibly touch Mary.
But they did not know about you.
The letter mentioned that Mary’s
parents couldn’t bear to visit
the cemetery where their baby girl is buried.
Investigators hoped the letter
would compel the killer to visit
Mary’s grave. They kept surveillance on it
for months, but the killer never showed.
To this day, no one has been
charged for the Tylenol killings.
After the poisonings, some communities
banned trick-or-treating as a precaution.
Copycat crimes later cropped up but were never as
widespread or fatal as the original poisonings.
Nearly 30 years later, James Lewis self-published
a book called “Poison: The Doctor’s Dilemma.”
It’s a fictional thriller about a
mass catastrophe in a mid-western
city where underground water supplies
have been poisoned, and people are dying.
Lewis has denied any link between
his book and the Tylenol poisonings.
It's important to remember that responsible use of
medications and supplements can be vital
to maintaining your health and well-being.
For more than a year, I’ve been supplementing with
Magnesium Breakthrough as I used to struggle
with falling asleep and staying asleep.
I know how important it is to get a
good night’s sleep to keep my mind
sharp and productive, as I can spend
as much as 12 hours a day, every day,
working on mini-documentaries like this video
that take a lot of time to put together.
I had no clue that 75% of
people are magnesium deficient,
which can lead to higher levels of anxiety,
irritability, low energy, and trouble sleeping.
It’s also important to get the right
kind of magnesium. That's why I trust
Magnesium Breakthrough, which has helped me get
better sleep, and I find I wake up less tired.
Magnesium Breakthrough is the
only organic full-spectrum
magnesium supplement that includes
seven unique forms of magnesium.
To try it out, visit
magbreakthrough.com/newsthink to order
and get 10% off with by promo code: NEWSTHINK
10 and if you use my promo code NEWSTHINK.
My custom link is in my description.
Thanks for watching. I’m Cindy Pom.